leticia variants eldest grandson alexis
is sick with dengue fever and has been
in this public hospital for several
weeks now but he isn't the only one
across the hall her two other grandsons
are also being treated for a measles
infection six-year-old Prince ander and
four year-old James Mateo she says she
is somehow grateful that her
grandchildren made it to the hospital in
time it has been very difficult seeing
my grandsons like this but I have no
choice I have to be strong san lazaro
hospital is just one of the many
hospitals where patriotic wards have
been overflowing with children sick with
infectious diseases the Department of
Health has recorded at least 40,000
cases of measles across the country
since January and more than 500 patients
have died while the cases of those with
dengue have reached more than 270,000
with more than a thousand 100 dead many
of those who died were children but it
doesn't end there the government has
announced the return of polio type 2 an
incurable disease that was eradicated 19
years ago public trust on vaccine has
plummeted according to the global
vaccine confidence index from 93 percent
now down to 32 percent which means now
that only one out of five Filipinos
believe that vaccines are safe the
health secretary says a recent
investigation into a vaccination
campaign against dengue fever by the
public Attorney's Office is partly to
blame for the falling vaccination rates
this kind of issue is best discussed in
a scientific forum by scientists doctors
and professionals and should not be in a
Senate hearing or on television with
people who are uninformed and educated
about the issue making definitive
comments the Philippine government says
it promises to roll out a series of
nationwide immunization programs but
back at the intensive care unit of San
lázaro hospital every second counts
there's a sense of urgency here and
parents are desperate for their children
to recover
Chameli Logan al-jazeera Manila